der wecker klingelt um 7 uhr der wecker
klingelt um sieben uhr aufstehen
aufstehen es sieben uhr
es ist 7 uhr aufstehen aufstehen ss7 uhr
[Musik]
guten morgen guten morgen
ja ja ich stehe ihr auf ja ja ich stehe
hier auf
ich schaltete das licht ein
ich schalte das licht ein
ich gehe durch den gang
ich gehe eher durch den gang
er fuhr er fort er vor rostocks
entschuldigung ups entschuldigung
ich gehe ins badezimmer
ich muss aufs klo ich muss aufs klo
ich denke ich pinkeln ich wasche meine
hände
ich wasche meine hände
ich putze die zähne
ich nehme eine dusche
ich ziehe die unterhose an
ich ziehe das unterhemd an
[Musik]
ich ziehe die besorgten an
ich ziehe die socken an
ich ziehe die hose an
ich ziehe das hemd an
ich ziehe die schuhe an
was machst du was machst du
ich mache kaffee ich mache kaffee
am morgen brauche ich kaffee am morgen
brauche ich kaffee
warum warum warum
mit kaffee werde ich wach mit kaffee
werde ich wach
ich schneide brot ich schneide brot du
ist zu schnell du ist zu schnell so ist
zu schnell
ich habe hunger ich habe hunger
ich hab ich auch ich auch ich auch
ich mache dir ein müsli
mit banane mit banane mit kirsche mit
kirsche
mit kiwi mit kiwi und mit erdbeere und
mit erdbeere lecker ich liebe bräuchte
lecker ich liebe früchte
es ist halb neun ich muss zur arbeit
es ist halb neun
ich muss zur arbeit
was ist ein beruf was ist dein beruf
ich bin super held ich bin super held
ich probiere ich pausiere
ich hänge herum ich hänge herum
ich mache feuer ich mache feuer
ich rette menschen aus dem feuer
ich lösche feuer ich lösche feuer
ich renne davon
ich bin erschöpft
ich schäme mich ich schäme mich
ich bin müde
ich gehe hier nach hause ich gehe nach
hause
ich trinke ein bier und sie fern
ich trinke ein bier und seehäfen
ich schaue die tagesschau ich schaue die
tagesschau
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla ich bin schließlich bla bla
bla bla bla bla ist
der waldbrand der waldbrand
die überschwemmung die überschwemmung
der wirbelsturm der wirbelsturm
alleine kann ich die welt nicht retten
ich schaue noch die serie familie
schröder
ich schaue noch diese rhi familie
schröder die liebe ich die liebe ich die
liebe ich habe ja schon ich mache weiter
ich mache weiter
hilf mir die welt zu retten
hat dir das video gefallen abonniere
unseren kanal hat dir das video gefallen
abonniere unseren kanal